space entrepreneur jane pointer joins us
now um she set up her own space company
used by american commercial spacecraft
hello t thanks for joining us on the
program
so good morning good morning how's this
work
so we are taking people to space in a
very gentle way right i think when most
of us think about space flight
we think about rockets and training and
space suit the right stuff
so we want to find a way to take people
to space that's incredibly gentle so
that we all feel that we can go to space
and so we're using
a huge space balloon that is the size of
a football field taking a very
comfortable pressurized capsule to space
and of course you can have your beverage
of choice on board we have a bar and a
loo of course and wi-fi
every self-respecting spaceship has a
bar i believe
um how much will it cost
so hours costs 125 000 a piece there are
of course other ways to get to space
which are vastly more expensive so we're
pretty excited that we are going to
space but we are able to really bring
the cost down significantly already and
we're pretty excited about the the
uptake that we've had the demand is huge
we put tickets on sale earlier this year
in february we've already sold over 450
tickets so people really want to go to
space
um how long can they stay there
so our flight is six hours long it takes
you roughly two hours to get to space
you're going there
at a blazing 12 miles an hour then
you're going to be up at apogee at the
top for two hours so that you can look
out the windows 360 degree panoramic
view to have that incredible view of
earth in space that astronauts talk
about like it really moves them when
they see that view and then two hours
down again
um what are the risks
so this is truly the safe way to go to
space
the space balloon that we are flying a
pressurized capsule with
has been used by nasa and others
thousands of times and so of course it
that has really tested the technology
and put it through its paces and then
between the capsule and the balloon
there is of course a parachute and it's
a pre-deployed parachute and this kind
of system has been used also thousands
of times and has never failed in all of
that time so it's an incredibly safe way
to go to space
um
who are your customers clients what do
you call them passengers
we call them explorers actually because
we want really won't think that people
are are discovering a new perspective a
new way of seeing a planet
uh at the moment our customers about 80
of them are from the us because frankly
that's largely where our press has been
so we're super happy to talk to you
today because we want to invite
everybody from uk and around the world
to come and join us on this great
mission uh and i would say that a lot of
them are men but i we are also seeing a
lot of women coming on board because
it's so accessible which is super
and what's really fun is that we're
seeing people buying up four capsules so
that that which is eight people and a
pilot
and that way they can take their entire
family they can get a group of friends
together to go so it's really becoming a
social event in space which is really
awesome to see
how eco-friendly is it
yeah that's a great question so this is
essentially a
near-zero emissions space flight
and as a company we're also carbon
neutral
which is amazing um how far i mean you
said 125 000 pounds i said that's uh
unfo affordable for a vast majority of
people how quickly before that price
starts to come down yeah so i
to be fair we have such huge demand it
is quite likely that the price will go
up a little bit before it comes down we
do certainly have a long-term vision of
getting the price down but you know
what's exciting for us because this is
so accessible we're able to involve
such a broad swap of people who
otherwise really just couldn't consider
going to space i'm also excited that
we're involving scientists artists of
all kinds poets painters sculptors
writers you know i think it's incredibly
important that we do make this
extraordinary experience available to
people who can experience it in
different ways and then communicate it
in different ways you know when you talk
to astronauts about their experience of
seeing earth in space it's not just a
pretty view that they're looking at for
them it is deeply emotional and moving
and they have this incredible connection
with our planet and what they think of
as the singular human family on
spaceship earth
and and that's a very important and
moving experience for them and we want a
lot of people to be able to experience
it and communicate it in a variety of
different ways and when's the first
flight jane
yeah so we're going up at our first
commercial flight around the end of 2024
and our first human test flight will be
in 2023. so it's soon
yeah exciting stuff keep in touch thank
you very much thank you